foreign
is just around the corner welcome to
this DW business special on what we can
expect I'm Ben fazolin in Berlin and I'm
joined by Economist carsten pajeski from
the ING Bank thanks for being with us
thanks for having me
well let's whiz through the numbers
before we get started the international
monetary fund is warning that over a
third of the world economy is headed for
contraction this year or next China the
Eurozone and the United States will
continue to stall the IMF says this
year's sharks will reopen economic
wounds that were only partially healed
post-pandemic it's World economic
Outlook shows growth withering from six
percent last year and 3.2 this year to
just 2.7 next year one factor is that
central banks are hiking interest rates
to ease inflation that's taking the heat
out of domestic demand but of course
you've also got the war in Ukraine it
sparked an energy crisis it's also
blocked Food Supplies driving up prices
and there's China's zero covert strategy
that's hit trade hard it also faces a
property Market crisis
we'll also look at the UK economy also
on the brink of recession and its
political crisis as well as how the
Russian economy is faring almost eight
months into its War
the IMF has stressed throughout this
week's meetings of Finance Chiefs that
the priority is for governments to keep
budgets tight and for central banks to
tight monetary policies to control
inflation I asked an IMF official about
that
the number one challenge is to tame this
inflation which is at multi-decade highs
and we do think that they are doing the
right thing by raising rates around the
world this is an unprecedented amount of
monetary tightening but it's necessary
to do the job of of bringing inflation
down now if they allow this problem to
fester and tap off the you know ease of
the brakes then we could have a much uh
Harder Job later on bringing inflation
under control
well Carston how bad a recession is this
going to be what sort of job are we all
uh facing right now
one thing we see a different shape of
recession that you're on it's also when
you look at these design F numbers so we
see more or less the cyclical recession
triggered by higher interest rates that
we're going to see in the US and then we
see recessions
um that are more severe because they're
also more structurally driven that is
what we're seeing in China where there's
a structural issue with the property
Market but that's also what we see in a
mainly in Europe where we have an
ongoing energy crisis an ongoing war and
and an entire region which has benefited
tremendously over the last decades from
globalization and world trade and which
will now really be kind of squeezed from
two sides High Energy prices and a
structural change to uh to globalization
we had it easy for a long time with
interest rates historically low and uh
for such a long time interest rates are
set to go up even further though and
stay up there for quite some time how
much suffering will that create
well a lot of suffering and we already
see this that every change comes with
suffering any every adjustment comes
with suffering that's what we're
currently seeing in financial markets to
start with and there is ongoing turmoil
an equity Market in bond markets because
markets have to adjust to this new
reality of lower growth higher inflation
and higher interest rates but also we
citizens
um we'll notice it higher interest rates
means that it will be much less
affordable to buy a house it also means
taking up credits taking up a loan will
become much more expensive so we will
see that these higher interest rates
even though we haven't inflation which
is mainly driven by Energy prices we are
now seeing central banks trying to slow
down the demand side slowing down
consumption slowing down investment and
that's going to be painful
but those higher interest rates are
going to stifle demand so at some stage
we're going to be faced with this
problematic of trying to get demand back
up there as well
indeed and that is of course also would
be the contradictory thing that we see
in Western economies from Western
governments right now how they try to
tackle inflation or higher energy prices
because here we see that governments
have started to support
um the demand side of the economy they
have started to support households
disposable incomes there are subsidies
given there are also there will be
support for companies so this is
actually where the government enters the
picture it will not help bringing down
inflation but it's at least stabilizing
the demand side the other thing of
course that could happen is that central
banks at some point in time notice that
they actually were too aggressive and
that they actually got carried away in
their task to bring down inflation so
that we will see rates interest rates
being cut again and I personally think
that we will see the US the fed the
cutting interest rate in the second half
of next year already
okay but not this here because the jobs
Market there is looking very strong and
I mean the more jobs going around uh the
higher wages could be pushed up and the
higher inflation goes
correct and that is also a very
interesting thing of this specific
recession
in the industrialized countries because
this is a recession which hopefully will
not leave big marks on the labor market
because we have this structural shift of
demographics aging there is already this
demand of qualified workers in the US in
Europe so even when the demand side
comes down now I think we will not see a
big surge on unemployment what we're
going to see is clearly an impact on the
wage demands so I would expect that we
will see on the back of higher interest
rates on the back of the recession that
we'll also see that wage growth will
come down and this is obviously a trend
a development that central banks really
would like to see and would appreciate
because if it doesn't
um as the managing director of the IMF
has pointed out uh runaway inflation
could take hold and then there are the
knock-on effects for poverty and hunger
for example
I want to be to be clear the reason we
are
endorsing a strong focus on inflation is
because inflation has been quite
stubborn and the risk of inflation
expectations
de-anchoring has become
more uh visible
we cannot we cannot possibly allow
inflation to become a runaway a train
bad for growth and bad for people but as
bad especially for poor poor people for
poor people
and we need stronger efforts to confront
food insecurity
345 million people are acutely food
insecure what it means is that their
children and women and men are at risk
of dying
because of hunger
or parts of the world castam were
already facing a hunger crisis has it
just got worse
of course it has and she is fully right
so we have this High inflation High
Energy prices High food prices these two
are obviously related to each other so
we that and what in some Western
economies might only be a financial
issue is in many other countries an
issue of life and death and that's only
the price element so don't forget I
think what we what is not ex let's say
adequately in all these forecasts is the
fact that we have this ongoing war in
Ukraine that the Ukraine is extremely
important for important for food
production so I'm a bit afraid that we
will not only see this price effect but
we will also see a food supply problem
going into 2023 and this would make this
poverty the hunger issue the famine
issue even more severe
um to bring this uh back to the personal
level for so many people around the
world not just those facing hunger and
even worse
um Carson you mentioned it before the
state has been bailing out the people
rather than Banks a huge development
when it comes to equity around the world
uh and equality
tell me the state has only just spent an
entire pandemic bailing out the people
is it going to be able to continue that
will it be able to afford that
that is a very good question and when
you look at financial markets in recent
weeks and particularly what happened in
in the UK when the UK government
announced a big fiscal stimulus package
and all of a sudden we saw Bond deals
going through the roof as a reaction at
financial markets seemed to doubt the um
the fiscal sustainability of the British
government it shows us that there are
limits to what governments can spend I
think to put it into into perspective in
Europe but I also taken the U.S into
account the Western economies during the
pandemic they spent between 10 and 15 of
their GDP to stimulate and support the
economies during the pandemic so we're
currently seeing all countries
individually trying to support
households trying to solve support
businesses and it amounts to something
like five to six percent of GDP does
this mean that there are still more room
to do more it could but it could also
mean that there are limits to what
governments can actually doing the
current crisis if they don't want to be
hit by much higher interest rates and by
being punished by financial markets as
it means that investors would be
withdrawing their money from these
countries that spent too much to support
their economies
well let's stay with the British
government you brought that up the
government's very new but it went the
way of spending up big and tax cuts that
seem to be unfunded according to
analysts that's what was causing the
market turmoil and has now cost the job
of the Finance Minister let's just
listen into the debate a little earlier
in the week
we are seeing interest rates Rising
globally we are doing they are right our
Rising globally
in the face of Putin's appalling war in
Ukraine and what we're making sure is
that we protect our economy there's very
difficult
we will see higher growth and lower
inflation lost in denial no wonder
investors have no confidence in her
government
who voted for this
who voted for this there's no point
there's no point when will she stop
ducking responsibility do the right
thing and reverse her Kamikaze budget
which is causing so much pain Mr Speaker
I think the last thing we need is a
general election
[Applause]
Under Fire In The House of Commons
British prime minister Liz truss this
week facing lawmakers for the first time
since her tax cutting mini budget caused
turmoil on the markets and sent the
pound plunging Carston uh let's bring
you back in is this what happens to
countries that get it wrong because so
much of the world is moving in the same
direction right now as far as
governments and their relationship to
central banks go is this what happens
when they get it wrong they they get
punished do they
I I think this is indeed what happens if
they got it wrong it also happens
um you know in the case of the UK
probably if you are no longer Under the
Umbrella of a bigger continent I think
that that might have also played a role
here because the UK is really on its own
and I think what the biggest mistake
here where where the text Cuts now the
idea is actually not too bad so what did
the government do the Government tried
to support the demand side try to
support incomes and companies I think we
see other countries doing the same
um but what they should have done
instead of cutting taxes would have been
for example an investment program an
investment program showing that they aim
at improving the potential growth of the
economy in investing in infrastructure
investing in energy Supply because I
think that is what's currently needed
and I don't want to be in the shoes of
any politician right now because it is
extremely difficult to make the right
decisions they try to square the circle
here you need to bring short-term relief
to your economy while at the same time
bring trans structural transition on
track and that is very difficult
well it's also about uh ensuring access
to credit isn't it and and not so
widespread but also targeted credit to
groups that need it most so the more
vulnerable and the poor
that is that is exactly what it is but
that we see that apparently governments
are overwhelmed by the speed of this
crisis that sometimes technically well
think of Germany it is impossible to to
give more targeted stimulus because I
know due to privacy reasons due to the
lack of digitalization but of course
ideally this fiscal support would be
extremely tailor-made to the ones who
need it the most so the ones with low
income the companies that are at the
Brinks of going bus and then at the same
time Target the supply side think about
what does your economy need in the
coming years how do you change the
energy Supply this requires time
patience but also big Investments
and uh we seem to be running out of time
carsten as a chief Economist how do you
build strong fundamentals in a shock
prone world but also how do you do it
overnight
you can't do it overnight because we
have democracies
um and there is discussion and
discussion these days simply took takes
too long
um I think the um the only thing that
you can criticize here is that many
governments somehow didn't see that
coming even though since February 24th
it was obvious that we're gonna be
heading into a energy crisis in Europe
um that Europe is gonna lease enter and
lose International competitiveness and
that governments should have reacted
earlier than they did currently
and that energy crisis thanks to Russia
uh it's very interesting to look at the
numbers right now and see how Russia is
seemingly faring better than expected
considering its war in Ukraine
faring better I'm not faring well that's
important but what happened obviously
um there are sanctions which only
gradually start to bite and then there's
energy exports and yes there is less
energy export there's less export in oil
and gas but prices have gone through the
roof so this is what still helps the
Russian economy to get these revenues
and to support the economy but let's not
forget so Russia is experiencing a
severe recession it's only not as severe
as many analysts had thought at the
start of the war
Carson what about the complexity for
developing economies finally
extremely complex we touched upon the
high food prices this is this is a
severe issue for um for emerging
economies
we also see that with this change in
interest rates so with central banks
hiking interest rates there is also an
influent Capital especially to the US
the lettuce Capital that goes out of
Emerging Markets Capital that is uh that
is urgently needed to bring investments
into emerging economies and in order to
bring up to bring up the economic
potential of these economies so we will
see and that's actually what we've
always saw that in in periods of
aggressive interest rate hikes in the
U.S
Emerging Markets very often suffered it
might be a bit different this time
around there will be more
diversification I think we need to
distinguish between the Emerging Markets
the ones with relatively stable
political systems plus the ones
exporting Commodities should do
relatively well the others will probably
really hit a lot by this complete
paradigm shift that we see in the global
economy
well it has to be different this time
round doesn't it I mean we're not in the
same position we were prior to the 2008
financial crisis banks are so much more
robust regulation is Tighter and as
we've mentioned governments aren't
bailing out Banks they're bailing out
the people
Dan I think some if there is something
that we all have learned over the last
decade it is you know always be
extremely cautious believing an
economist telling you that this time is
different
um it might somehow be different
um but you know that it is never really
completely different uh when you look
back at his economic history since World
War II
every single recession was triggered by
aggressive rate hikes globally and that
is something we're happy we're also
witnessing right now for for Justified
reasons but but it's always every
recession has been kind of uh you know
been Advanced by by strong Ray tags this
is happening now how this will play out
you're fully right this is not the
financial crisis again we Financial
system is much more stable than in the
past we learned our lessons but there
will always be ways through which this
shift
in policies they shift in monetary
policy will find its way into the global
economy and that is what we're currently
seeing that is what the IMF is
predicting the IMF is not predicting the
end of the world that's also very clear
the IMF is predicting the Slowdown The
Slowdown that that will see recession
technical recession in many regions but
the IMF is also not predicting a kind of
gloom and doom slowdown which leads to
mass unemployment in many countries this
is not what's going to happen
lastly can you give us a little bit of
Hope to finish on how much hope is there
that governments and central banks will
together tame inflation Master this
recession and perhaps cushion it for all
of us
well I think to take away home as a
starter I think there are with these
situations there's always the risk of
overshooting so there is always the risk
of making a policy Mistake by hindsight
um the optimistic the hope is clearly
um that this change now in interest
rates
also means that there is you know we
have imbalances in the global economy we
had imbalances and and excessive Trends
in parts of financial markets so this
should lead to some normalization what
it also means if governments do it right
so if governments do not only cushion
the short-term impact of the recession
but use this recession as as a means and
as a trigger to really get this energy
transition going which means longer term
structural change then it could bring
Innovation could bring you investment
could bring forward renewable energies
so this is the hope that I'm having not
in the short term but at least in the
medium term that this is finally a
crisis and we heard this so often that
this is a crisis which will make the
global economy better unfortunately only
after a couple of years
some hope there for the people and the
planet from Carson brazewski Chief
Economist ing Germany thank you so much
for your time and for joining us for
this DW business special
and thank you for watching there's
plenty more from the business team on
the DW news YouTube channel until next
time take care